where are the writers of this show
they've handed me a note to cover the
next category says quote do not dwell on
subject make a simple statement pointing
out this most indispensable group in
filmmaking as throwaway say they are shy
underpaid often handsome OSE yet to
present the Writing Awards a man who
began by framing gangsters in 1930 1964
is training Picasso as one of the great
all-time stars of the cinema mr. Edgar G
Robert
the nominees for the best screenplay
based on material from another medium
are Richard L green Phoebe and Henry
Efron the captain Newman MD Irving
ravage and Harriet Frank jr. for HUD
James Poe lilies of the field says
Boogie neon and Antoine to doubt Sundays
and C bells and John Osborne Tom Jones
the winner is the winner is John Osborne
but Tom Jones
excepting for John Osborne Ivan gone
on behalf of John Osborne thank you very
much
the nominees for best story and
screenplay written directly for the
screen are this looks a little less
formidable give me a hand here please
yes well the first one is not too bad
nominees are story and screenplay by
Elia Kazan for America America story and
screenplay by Federico Fellini hmm - Leo
- Elly any old fly Otto and Brunello
Ronde for Federico Fellini's eight and a
half I think you did that rather well
really Jack story and screenplay by
James our web for How the West was won
story by Pasquale testa Campanelli miss
massimo Franchione
Nani Loy and Bosco Pratt aleni
screenplay by Carlo Benari thanks Eddie
Campanella massimo Franchi also and Nani
life or the four days of Naples and
story and screenplay by are now the shul
money oh I'm sorry really stranger and
the women
James aware how the west was won
took me about as long to win this that
did - in the West I would like to thank
a great day producer three great
directors hat flawless approved the
former's and a screenwriter named John
Gay who rode to the rescue in many a
moment of dire peril thank you so much